here at Abby's kitchen we love Jen em
for her fun and aesthetic Beauty and
Fashion content and more recently for
her relatable mom life Vlogs but weight
loss advice
I'm a bit scared hey everyone I'm Abby
sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video we'll be sharing my
thoughts on Jen im's weight loss journey
and giving my unfiltered critique and
commentary on her tips super quick
please be sure to check out my
disclaimer as we will be talking about
intentional weight loss today and please
share this video it really helps others
who need to find it and also don't
forget to hit up my description for my
free Hunger crush and combo ebook Okay
so a little backgrounder here Jen gave
birth in October 2021 after which
according to her she was the heaviest
weight she had ever been and despite
feeling comfortable with the way she had
looked she knew that she wanted to get
back to her pre-pregnancy weight without
going through the same tired cycle of
yo-yo dieting that she would go through
in the past it's probably something we
can all relate to my diet plan was not
very chill it was a lot of no's like no
rice no bread no pasta no noodles no
sugar no ice cream no cakes it was only
going to be salads and chicken and
vegetables once my diet started I would
be a very quote unquote good I would
just be exercising every single day I
would find myself partying every single
weekend and I would always think that
the cure to my hangover would be
dominoes Carby a corn dog at this point
I already had a bad first meal so I
might as well treat myself to another
and another one and then that
conveniently leads us back to phase one
so this was generally the cycle that I
caught myself in ah yes
[Music]
Jen perfectly articulates why heavy
restriction does not work for
sustainable weight loss it is the
starting point of the binge restrict
repent repeat cycle and is one of the
greatest clinical predictors of a binge
diet culture tells us that anytime we
end up in this cycle and our diet
doesn't work it's just because our
willpower wasn't strong enough or we
didn't try harder or we need to try a
different diet instead it is not your
fault and as I discussed Ad nauseam in
my video on permanent weight loss right
here your body has a ton of compensatory
mechanisms in place that help to drive
this cycle so let's take a look what her
plan is this time around I just followed
these guidelines that I'm about to share
with you to get gently back into shape
physically and also mentally therapy
throughout the years has definitely
helped me become more compassionate with
myself and my body image okay so I'm
liking what I'm hearing so far step one
ditch what no longer serves us even if
it's faster or everyone around us still
insists that it's the way to success
your lived experience obviously suggests
otherwise step two get to the root of
your why and therapy is a really great
way to unpeel the onion and better
understand your motivations your goals
and if changing your body is going to
fix the inherent problem sometimes it
will and sometimes it will not then step
three focus on gentle nutrition
compassion for yourself and acts of
self-care not self-control but I'll go
into more details on that in a minute I
just wanted to make a little quick
disclaimer letting you guys know that I
did not follow any of these diet tips
I'm about to say until after I finished
breastfeeding meaning that I did not
modify my diet or watched what I ate so
I am so glad that Jen added this
disclaimer because despite the mounting
pressure on women to immediately bounce
back postpartum breastfeeding mamas
actually need an additional like 350 to
500 calories a day to support their milk
supply sometimes it's actually like
twice that much if you are really in the
trenches or you're an over producer or
pumping most women find that if we
restrict our calories at all our supply
tanks that runs out and if you struggle
with breastfeeding like me that is just
like not a risk we are willing to take
and even though breastfeeding does burn
around 20 calories per ounce it doesn't
necessarily melt the baby weight away as
we've all so often been promised in fact
some women actually gain weight while
breastfeeding because of increases in
stress hormones appetite sleep
disturbances and the fat storage hormone
prolactin so I just want to put that out
there to normalize any kind of
unexpected weight fluctuations
postpartum because it is all a bit of a
roller coaster to say the least
I began reflecting some data I
calculated my tdee which stands for
total daily energy expenditure now this
is gonna vary wildly depending on each
person because we are all different but
according to my body stats I would only
need around 1500 to 1600 calories every
day now my tdee is lower because I am
petite I'm only five foot one in general
I think predictive equations can be a
helpful tool to get a very rough
estimate of your needs but that is
really exactly what it is just a really
really crude estimate there's typically
like a five to fifteen percent margin of
error depending on which equation you
decide to use and when you look at the
many many different activity factors you
could be looking at like a 500 calorie
discrepancy depending on what you go
with so yeah most best professionals
only use this as a very rough estimate
to keep in the back of our mind in
reality our caloric needs natural
fluctuate on a day-to-day basis
depending on things like sleep energy
expenditure stress hormones will be at
the day before Etc and Let Me Tell You
Folks our hormones they're still kind of
up immediately after you wean so
usually in practice we prefer to track
normal food intake for several days
ideally both during the weekdays and on
the weekends and then apply a small 10
to 20 percent deficit to what's already
going on naturally and this will
generally result in a one to two percent
weight loss or around one percent body
weight loss per week which is considered
a safe amount to preserve our muscle
mass I just slashed maybe like 100
calories to 50 calories a day and it
wasn't super strict about it like
looking at all the nutrition facts
instead I would just be like hey maybe
today I won't Splash milk in my coffee
or maybe instead of ketchup I would just
have hot sauce like it would just be
very small tweaks yes sustainable weight
loss to me always comes down to asking
yourself what changes can I make that
won't affect the joy in my life like
that are not going to make me miserable
or cranky or hangry Etc I generally
don't recommend changing people's coffee
order because for most people coffee or
tea is like a sacred daily ritual I
don't know my whole day would be messed
up if I was to swap my latte for black
coffee
cream no thank you I take it black but I
mean obviously there are a lot of people
who aren't as attached to their usual
starvies order so if this works for her
I love it it works for me I'm like a
volume eater so this is where
intermittent fasting has just benefited
me immensely I have 1500 calories for my
tdee so it made sense for me to eat two
large meals in a day and maybe a snack
so I fasted five days out of the week so
I've got a whole video where I break
down the research on intermittent
fasting for weight loss and I even have
a sister video on intermittent fasting
and female hormones so you guys can
definitely check those out right there
but my short and sweet breakdown
recommendations when it comes to
intermittent fasting is this if it
aligns with your natural hunger and
satiety cues if it doesn't leave you
feeling ravenous during your fasting
window to the point where it triggers a
binge when you Feast if it doesn't put
you in an extreme state of low energy
availability which I will mention in one
minute and if it doesn't have a negative
impact on your mental physical or social
well-being then I say like live your
best fasted life not to mention for some
people fewer eating episodes in the day
means more mental space in their brain
for other acts of Joy but it's worth
pointing out that the reason why
intermittent fasting works is not
because of its unique insulin
suppressing properties it's because we
just kind of suck at making up for
missed meals so naturally we create a
calorie deficit when we cut out one of
our meals and that is why the research
suggests that it's ultimately no better
than continuous caloric restriction on a
population level when it comes to weight
loss and in fact some people don't lose
weight when they're intermittent fasting
and some even will gain so it's really
not a one-size-fits-all situation
finally 16 hours is definitely on the
longer side for what's generally
recommended for women for fasting since
it can increase the risk of low energy
availability which can risk us going
below the critical threshold for
supporting hormonal health and again I
talked all about that in my intermittent
fasting and hormone video right here but
I would say as long as we're not doing
any heavy exercise and we're not
applying a super heavy caloric deficit
which it doesn't seem like Jen is I
think this way of eating sounds totally
fine I think it's important to focus on
eating Whole Foods that you genuinely
enjoy the taste of now Whole Foods are
ones that don't have a huge ingredient
list we love a whole food I mean they're
generally rich in nutrients antioxidants
fiber and in some cases water for
hydration so I think that focusing on
Whole Foods is a really great
evidence-based suggestion however this
is just a friendly reminder that the
length of an ingredient list is really
not indicative of its healthfulness
fortified dairy milk Greek yogurt whole
grain cereal or bread all of these foods
are considered to be processed foods and
all of them have multiple ingredients
some of which maybe you can't even
pronounce if you're not familiar with
things like coal calciferol or
lactobacillus lacti but they are all
great additions to a lot of weight loss
diets and for good reason and yes
honestly even more processed less new
foods can have their place in a weight
loss diet so of course focusing on Whole
Foods is a great guideline but there's
no need to make Whole Foods only a hard
and fast Rule and when I'm prepping my
meals I always think about adding for
example let's say I'm eating some mac
and cheese instead of just having it
with the noodles and cheese I will add
broccoli peas a chicken a protein and
then I also have like mixed greens on
the side I will eat pretty much
everything but I will just throw a bunch
of vegetables at it and it kind of
shifts my perspective into a place of
abundance rather than scarcity you know
what I mean instead of saying like oh I
can't have pizza I'll just say I'll have
pizza and I'll also have a big salad
with it
um has this girl been watching Abby's
kitchen I mean I just know all you guys
at home are like cheering her on like I
am
but you guys know my Approach has always
been additive for the same reason that
Jen stated when we restrict we fall into
scarcity mentality which sets off our
propensity to binge when we focus on
abundance and when we can add to our
diet we can have our cake and eat it too
and this is the basis of my Hunger
crushing combo which while not a weight
loss diet per se absolutely can be
utilized to support gentle weight loss
goals like I would not beat yourself
over eating too much fruit or eating too
many avocados uh berries will not
inherently make you fat because of all
the carbs they contain like the keto
kids insists and avocados won't
inherently make you fat because of all
the fat it contains like the low fat
calorie counters suggest these foods are
hyper nutritious foods that are rich in
hunger crushing compounds plus loads of
antioxidants that do the body good
obviously we don't want to live solely
off produce because protein is King in
this tidy hierarchy and arguably the
most important macro when it comes to
weight loss but fiber rich fruits and
Whole Food fats are Primo diet foods in
my opinion it's the processed shot
that's gonna make you gain weight and
processed foods are the ones with just
like a lot of ingredients like like the
processed foods are all the foods that
are located in the center of the grocery
store
um not necessarily like again there's a
difference between Ultra process and
processed as we just discussed and sure
you'll find a lot of ultra processed
lower nutrition Foods in the middle of
the store but if you just follow the
store Perimeter rule blindly you would
also be missing out on Frozen produce
beans and legumes whole grains oats nuts
seeds and olives Etc also processed food
doesn't inherently make you gain weight
and excess of calories does and while of
course Ultra processed foods tend to be
easier to over consume it doesn't mean
that they can't fit in a weight loss
diet I think the only tip I have for
exercise is to find a form of movement
that you enjoy and just be consistent
with it I love Pilates I love walking
running hiking strength training yoga
it's a blend of everything because I do
believe that variety is the spice for
life she's using all my favorite
taglines I love it oh I'm so proud but I
do think exercise needs to undergo a
major conscious uncoupling from weight
loss I mean our caloric intake is made
up of about 100 of the food we eat the
physical activity only makes up about 10
to 30 percent of our caloric expenditure
and only a small subset of that is an
intentional exercise our body also has a
ton of compensatory mechanisms in place
to conserve energy and maintain energy
balance so for example we tend to eat
more after we exercise and unconsciously
just fidget lesser move less doing basic
acts of living so even though it's not
really that helpful at supporting active
weight loss efforts exercise is great
for preserving muscle dieting and for
maintaining weight that's been lost it's
also invaluable for improving mood
energy levels cognition Sleep Quality
regularity bone health and even blood
markers like cholesterol and blood
pressure I say this not to discourage
people from exercising but rather to
encourage them to continue even if or
when their diet ends or fails my final
tip is that slow and steady wins the
race anytime that I've lost weight and
I've kept it off it's been through a
very gradual process and anytime I went
on something too restrictive or I was
like crash dieting then my weight would
just yo-yo I would like gain back that
weight so quickly and maybe even a
little bit more raise your hand if
you've been personally victimized by the
crash yoyo diet
remember folks as I discussed in my
video on permanent weight loss right
here losing weight is a marathon not a
Sprint and if there's any rule you
should follow on any weight loss Journey
it's to be gentle and compassionate with
yourself do not demand extremes from
your body do not punish your body or
deprive it of its needs and do not force
it to follow an unrealistic timeline all
in all a lot of Jen's weight loss tips
align with my own recommendations for
gentle weight loss such as approaching
weight loss as a long game having an
abundance mindset and prioritizing Whole
Foods and joyful movement do we need to
completely avoid processed foods or
longer ingredient list no I mean that
definitely feels unnecessary but
regardless this generally does sound
like a recipe for success and I wish Jen
the best of luck on her journey and if
you are looking for even more
sustainable weight loss tips I've got a
whole video on exactly that which you
can watch right here and on that note
that's all that I have for you guys
today I would love to hear your thoughts
on who or what you'd like to see me
review next subscribe to the channel and
I'll see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]